ich möchte
sechs wichtige punkte ihnen vorstellen
die ich mit meiner kandidatur begründe
weil sie nach meiner einschätzung mit
der zukunft der cdu und auch unseres
landes aufs engste verbunden sind
der erste punkt die cdu ist die partei
der mitte die partei der mitte zu sein
heißt dass es zwingend notwendig ist
dass diese parteigrenzen zieht nach
rechts und links
wenn es nach einer seite keine grenzen
gibt dann wären wir nicht mehr die
partei der mitte zweiter
die cdu ist die partei der deutschen
einheit
und weil wir das sind dürfen wir nicht
und können wir nicht ignorieren dass
sich demokratische einstellungen und
praktiken zwischen ost und west in
deutschland auseinander entwickeln und
darum sollte die cdu einen deutschland
dialog über demokratie und demokratische
kultur in deutschland initiieren
ein dialog auf augenhöhe kann nicht
darin bestehen dass die westdeutschen
die ostdeutschen belehren wie was denn
selbstverständlich ist in der demokratie
drittens genauso klar wie die cdu
kompromisslos politisch geistig die
abgrenzung gegenüber der afg vollziehen
muss und immer wieder bestätigen muss
genauso eindeutig müssen wir die gründe
beseitigen die zur entstehung von
rechtsextremismus und rechtspopulismus
in deutschland geführt haben und
weiterführen
das was die bürger erlebt haben in der
krisen dekade von welt finanzmarktkrise
[Musik]
einen massiven vertrauensbruch
über die euro-krise eine vertrauenskrise
in die währung bis hin zur
flüchtlingskrise ist überraschung der
politik überforderung der politik und
reagieren und reparieren wenn menschen
alleine gelassen werden und ihnen
sicherheit ein fundamental und den
praktisch allen bereichen genommen
werden
dann bekommen bürger angst und die angst
ist das geschäft der afd
vielleicht an ein zwei beispielen in
einem vierten punkt illustrieren was ich
damit meine ich habe vor einigen wochen
von einer verantwortlichen stelle die
aussage in einem interview gelesen
wir haben die migration nach deutschland
geordnet was stimmt ist dass die zahlen
von flüchtlingen die nach deutschland
gekommen sind im jahre 2009 10 deutlich
zurückgegangen sind und bei in der größe
von um die 160 tausend liegen aber von
ordnung der migration kann nicht die
rede sein
das ist noch nicht mal ein vorwurf dass
unterblieben ist so eine migration hat
tiefe ursachen wie man nicht so einfach
ordnen kann
aber wenn diese aussage gemacht wird und
ja auch hoffnung und tanz schafft dann
erleben wir in diesen tagen die
situation in idlib
seit einigen tagen schon seit einigen
wochen schon fast eine million menschen
schon heute vor den bomben assad und den
bomben aus der luft von der russischen
luftwaffe fliehen müssen
knapp eine million
diese situation wiederum hat die türkei
veranlasst mit mehreren tausend soldaten
nach app zu den und schwerem gerät und
je nachdem wie sich nun diese mal
interessen koalition zwischen händlern
putin und assad entwickelt kann es dort
auch zu einem weitergehenden krieg
führen
zwischen türkischen truppen türkei nato
mitglied und das hat und mit welcher
russischen beteiligung auch immer das
ist ein akutes geschehen über das wir
kaum sprechen wo wird darüber diskutiert
wann ist darüber begonnen worden
zu diskutieren wie gehen wir damit um
und dafür möchte ich werben dass wir
über solche sachverhalte schon sprechen
bevor sie als unverändertes szenario da
sind wir müssen und es muss uns gelingen
und es kann gelingen es ist doch absolut
möglich über das was wir kommen sehen
auch schon für reden wenn es sich
entwickelt die situation in europa ist
ein zweites thema wir sehen dass die
uneinigkeit weiter besteht
darum glaube ich ist das format e3
deutschland frankreich großbritannien
ein zukunfts format und darum muss es
gelingen dass zwischen frankreich und
deutschland konkrete projekte entstehen
und geliefert werden nicht allgemein
reden sind viele gehalten auch genug
sondern wir brauchen und es ist möglich
konkrete deutsch-französische projekte
mit denen geliefert wird der fünfte
punkt
die cdu muss ökologische glaubwürdigkeit
im allgemeinen und klimapolitische
glaubwürdigkeit im besonderen
zurückgewinnen
wahlentscheidend für die cdu wird sein
dass wir über zukunftskompetenz verfügen
und es ist ganz einfach ohne ökologische
kompetenz gibt es keine
zukunftskompetenz
der sechste punkt die cdu als partei der
mitte muss die gesellschaftliche mitte
ich glaube es gibt mehr und mehr und im
wesentlichen eine alternative gegenüber
den grund stürzenden veränderungen
unserer zeit die eine alternative ist
abschotten und ängste und die andere
option in dieser alternative ist sich
diesen veränderungen zu stellen
die bürger zu schützen offen zu bleiben
vernünftig zu bleiben und uns europäisch
zu verbünden und ich möchte dass die cdu
die partei ist die die zweite option
nicht geschildert habe die des schutzes
und der offenheit zugleich anführt